okay yeah you have a question love got
you these protesters don't want this man
to speak the speaker is Dave Rubin hello
internet my name is Dave Rubin I am the
newest host here on The Young Turks
he was once a leftist I obviously I'm
for Obamacare you and I both started on
the Left yeah why did you switch oh I
woke up he woke up he says after he
started doing a podcast and interviewed
guests like Larry elder the most blatant
racist example you can come up with
right now if cops are more willing to
shoot if the perpetrator is black what's
your date of NY what's your basis for
saying that 70% of the homicides are
black on black the idea that a racist
white cop and shooting unarmed black
people is apparel to black people is BS
and he just beat me with fact over fact
over fact about how systemic racism
doesn't exist not that racism doesn't
exist the more people they interview the
more he questions his former beliefs I
realized that not everyone that these
people disagreed with could be a racist
and a bigot and a homophobe and a sexist
and that was the argument that was
constantly being laid out if there was a
Republican that gave a speech and said
we should lower taxes their answer was
he's racist now that actually makes no
sense
Ruben now considers himself a classical
liberalism on his podcasts he tries to
interview people from the left and the
right should government subsidize gay
marriage and straight marriage the same
way Ruben was surprised that many people
on the right were willing to debate for
all the differences that we might have
on Protoss to them are pro-life you know
I'm against the death penalty most of
them are for the death penalty
they're all willing to sit down and
discuss ideas what I went from left to
libertarian the right was willing to
argue if you believe in the individual
then you fundamentally understand that
individuals are different so you are
willing to sit down with someone
different than you some of his podcasts
last one or more
I never thought that people would listen
to interviews that long but millions of
people watch I didn't know what was
gonna happen but I started doing more of
these long-form interviews and people
kept watching and then suddenly I
realized whoa there's a lot of people
that are thinking the things that I'm
thinking not just me by the way there's
Joe Rogan and there's others we're
allowing people to go all right
let's really listen to something let's
really unpack an idea you don't learn
anything when you watch CNN you will
actually be Dumber but having watched
CNN right guys we're live on the YouTube
because the Reuben report features some
controversial guests Milo I innopolis
welcome to the show and because he
sometimes criticizes leftists and maybe
because his podcasts are so successful
his former colleagues now hate him you
know the right-wing loves him now
because he's a puppet for the right-wing
he was lazy when he worked here he's
lazy now with his ridiculous show she
just sounds envious I lost friends I
still lose friends now I mean it's
incredible because because this goes to
the laziness of the argument of the left
they believe that there if you disagree
with them that you're evil evil is what
these protesters call ladies ladies I'll
gladly take a question from you have we
established that already they say just
allowing him to speak is a form of
violent
this woman said Reubens insensitive to
the victims on camp biased incidence
reports and hate crimes have gone up
yeah so and people have been spit on and
people have been threatened and people
have been told to go home to their
country it doesn't mean that bad people
don't exist but tell me about your
oppression maybe maybe we can work
through something I mean tell me about
your oppression what if I have no reason
to sit and talk about my own oppression
because that's just like mental energy
I'm going to be paid to an oppression
Olympics it's a hierarchy of oppressions
compressional limb yes so you've got to
figure out how you are oppressed if you
have a limp who you're this much
oppressed or if you're a Jew this much
oppressor or Muslim this mustard past
everyone wants to be oppressed
there's truth behind it blacks have been
oppressed women some still are women are
sometimes suppressed no society is
perfect but the United States by and
large has given more freedom to more
people from every walk of life
regardless of your skin color your
sexuality do we have problems yes we can
talk about all of those things but to
tell me those are things because you are
oppressed it ain't true and it needs to
that idea needs to be decimated